[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild MKO heute geht's nach Belgien und
Belgien ist bekannt für seine Pommes für
Pralinen und für Comics z.B Tim und
Struppi oder die Schlümpfe z.B alles
wirklich schöne Sachen ja schöne Sachen
und eine heile Welt aber diese heile
Welt in Belgien die ist nicht in dieser
Doppelfolge da geht es in ein Belgien in
dem sich Abgründe auftun tiefe Abgründe
denn ein Phantom treibt sein Unwesen ein
Phantom das junge Mädchen spurlos
verschwinden lässt heute geht es um
Belgiens schlimmsten Kidnapper
Vergewaltiger und Mörder es geht um Mark
D dieser Mann hat mit seinen Taten
Belgien ins Chaos gestürzt sogar an den
Rand eines Aufstands gebracht und darauf
das hat er selbst gesagt ist er auch
noch stolz ja wirklich unglaublich Mark
D als seine abscheulichen Taten Mitte
der 1990er an die Öffentlichkeit kommen
da steht nicht nur das kleine Land
Belgien unter Schock die Nachricht über
seine Verhaftung geht in kurzer Zeit um
die ganze Welt mag TR taten die machen
auch heute noch fassungslos aber nicht
nur die denn die Polizeiarbeit und der
Umgang der Justiz mit dro die werfen
ebenfalls Fragen auf wird Mar duutro von
höchster Stelle gedeckt ist er gar der
Kopf eines kriminellen Netzwerks das bis
in höchste Regierungskreise
reicht und damit herzlich Willkommen zu
tatot Deutschland heute stellen wir euch
den Fall Mark du vor den viele das
belgische Monster nenn und relativ
schnell werdet ihr auch wissen weshalb
ich bin B Ton und mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir Belgien beschaulich
fortschrittlich und friedlich doch
dieser Tag im Sommer
1995 der ändert alles es ist der 24 Juni
in der Gemeinde grasolon bei lüch zwei
Freundinnen machen sich auf um die Welt
zu entdecken Melissa rousau
undie beide sind Jahre alt also alt
genug ih Eltern auch mal alleine
losziehen lassen aber geht nicht so weit
weg von zu Hause ja bleib mal hier in
der Nähe genau das geben die Eltern
Melissa und jellie mit auf den Weg und
daran halten sich auch beide Kinder sie
bleiben in der Nähe ihrer Elternhäuser
beide sind auf einer kleinen
Erkundungstour durch die Nachbarschaft
Augenzeugen sehen die beiden Freundinnen
wie sie von einer Autobahnbrücke aus
vorbeifahrende Autos beobachten da ist
es ungefähr 17 Uhr und dann
verschwinden Melissa und Julie sie sind
einfach
weg die Mutter von Melissa Karin
Rousseau geht um 17:30 Uhr auf die Suche
nach den beiden Mädchen später beteiligt
sich auch die Mutter von Julie leenie
daran die Kinder scheinen verschwunden
um 18:45 Uhr verständigen die Eltern die
Gendamerie es beginnt eine Zeit voller
Ungewissheit nach 10 Tagen ohne Spur
wenden sich die Eltern beider Kinder an
die Presse
mit einer Botschaft für die
vermeintlichen Entführer der Mädchen wir
Flehen sie an geben sie uns unsere
Kinder zurück geben Sie uns ein Zeichen
dass sie leben und es ihnen gut geht wir
versprechen Ihnen dass wir Diskretion
Walen lassen und nichts tun damit sie
verfolgt werden unser einziges Ziel ist
es die Kinder
wiederzusehen die Eltern von Melissa und
Jie bangen um das Leben ihrer Töchter
und Sie werden nicht die einzigen Eltern
sein die in dieser Zeit vsorgen fast
wahnsinnig werden weil ihre Kinder
plötzlich
verschwindenko ja denn der Albtraum
beginnt gerade erst 8 Wochen später 200
km entfernt es ist der 22 August 1995 an
der belgischen
Nordseeküste die 17-jährige ann marchall
und ihre 19-Jährige Freundin evje
lambrex machen Campingurlaub mit
Freunden in
Blankenberge es ist ihr erster Urlaub
ohne Eltern auch die beiden entdecken
die Welt aber eben nicht als Achtjährige
sondern als Teenager auf eigenen Beinen
stehen zusammen feiern es soll ein
toller Urlaub
werden Spoiler wird es aber nicht denn
plötzlich sind beide wie vom Erdboden
verschluckt keiner weiß wo anmarchall
und eV lambrex stecken das letzte Mal
gesehen werden beide Frauen bei einer
Hypnoseshow die Sie besuchen und bei dir
sie auch mitmachen davon gibt es sogar
Filmaufnahmen für die 90er ja nicht
unbedingt
selbstverständlich nach der Show machen
sich beide auf den Rückweg zum
Campingplatz aber ankommen werden sie da
nicht wo sind sie was ist passiert die
Eltern von Ann und eje sind in Panik
aber die Behörden sind keine große Hilfe
der Vater von an bekommt von der Polizei
zu hören machen Sie sich keine Sorgen
die Kinder werden schon wieder
auftauchen die sind bestimmt losgezogen
erleben ein Abenteuer gehen sie nach
Hause warten Sie ab ja das ist natürlich
nicht unbedingt das was sich die Eltern
da Hilfe suchen von der Polizei erwarten
ne gehst hin möchtest eigentlich Hilfe
weil du in höchster Not bist und erntest
nur ein Schulterzucken das ist nicht
unbedingt toll ja definitiv und die
Eltern sind fassungslos
verständlicherweise und sie nehmen die
Sache selber in die Hand sie suchen
öffentlich nach ihren Kindern doch
niemand hat etwas gesehen keiner kann
Hinweise geben auch ein halbes Jahr nach
dem Verschwinden gibt es keine Spur von
ihn die Hoffnung an marchall und e
lambrex lebendig wiederzufinden die
schwindet von Tag zu Tag zumal auch hier
keine Lösegeldforderung eingeht und der
Horror geht weiter in Belgien es ist der
28 Mai
1996 die 12jährige Sabine darden fährt
mit ihrem Fahrer zur Schule das macht
sie jeden Tag doch an diesem Tag kommt
sie dort nicht an wie die vier Mädchen
vor ihr verschwindet Sabine plötzlich
aber dieses Mal gibt es einen ersten
Hinweis auf ein
Gewaltverbrechen Sabine wird von ihrem
Fahrrad gezerrt welches am Straßenrand
gefunden wird sabine ist jetzt das
fünfte Mädchen das im Belgien innerhalb
kurzer Zeit
verschwindet und so langsam macht sich
Panik in der Bevölkerung breit viele
Belgier lassen ihre Kinder kaum mehr
noch unbeaufsichtigt aus dem Haus denn
alle haben Angst Angst vor einem Phantom
dass es auf junge Mädchen abgesehen hat
die Polizei setzt eine Spezialeinheit
ein doch alle Spuren führen ins Nichts
keiner verknüpft die einzelnen Fälle
miteinander was auch daran liegt dass
die Mädchen nicht an einem bestimmten
Ort in Belgien verschwinden sondern im
ganzen Land die einen ganz im Norden die
anderen ganz im Süden es liegen mehrere
hundert Kilometer zwischen den Tatorten
keiner ahnt dass es sich jedes Mal um
denselben Täter handelt 10 Wochen später
verschwindet ein sechstes Mädchen
spurlos diesmal ganz im Süden von
Belgien die 14-Jährige Letizia delhe ist
auf dem Weg vom Schwimmbad nach Hause
als sie auf offener Straße entführt wird
doch dieses Mal gibt es Hinweise aus der
Bevölkerung ein Anwohner beobachtet
einen weißen Transporter der kommt ihm
irgendwie verdächtig vor er notiert sich
das Kennzeichen und meldet sich bei der
Polizei das verdächtige Auto in das
letizer gezerrt wurde ist zugelassen auf
den 39-Jährigen Arbeitslosen Elektriker
Mark dtrou ein Mann der schon lange
Polizei beeknt ist Mark drou und seine
Frau Michelle Martin werden vorgeladen
genauso wie der drogenabhängige Michelle
l livivre der durch zurückliegende
Straftaten an der Seite von drou
ebenfalls aktenkundig ist während d im
Polizeiverhör alles abstreitet knicken
die anderen beiden ein sie gestehen die
Entführung und belasten vor allem Mark
drou die Polizei ist sich sicher Sie
haben den richtigen Mark Duru hat
Letizia delhe entführt aber wo ist sie
ist sie noch am Leben Mar du Tru wird
erneut verhört und was er dieses Mal
sagt das überrascht die Ermittler es
lässt ihn das Blut in den Adern
gefrieren er sagt ich kann ihn sogar
zwei Mädchen geben
Letizia delhe und die verschwundene
Sabine daden die TR führt die Ermittler
zu einem Haus in der Gemeinde
charlerois dort finden die Beamten in
einer kleinen Kellerzelle letiti delhe
die seit se Tagen vermisst wird und die
vor 80 Tagen verschwundene Sabine
darden beide lebendig aber völlig
entkräftet zwei Mädchen die den wahren
Horror erlebt
haben
die gerettete Sabine daden berichtet was
ihr Mar D Tru furchtbares angetan hat
nachdem er sie entführt und weggesperrt
hat versucht er sie zu manipulieren er
kettet das Mädchen nackt ans Bett und
lügt ihr vor dass sie entführt wurde
ihre Eltern aber nicht auf die
Lösegeldforderung reagiert hätten was
natürlich nicht stimmt denn es hat nie
eine Lösegeldforderung gegeben richtig
Mar redet Sabin ein dass sie ihren
Eltern völlig egal ist und und er sie
jetzt eigentlich umbringen sollte weil
kein Lösegeld bezahlt wurde aber weil er
ja so ein netter Typ ist will er sie
beschützen wirklich sehr perfide er sagt
ihr alle haben dich im Stich gelassen du
bist auf dich allein gestellt aber gut
dass du jetzt bei mir bist ich rette
dich und für diese Rettung erwartet Mark
detro eine Gegenleistung Sabine wird
mehrfach
vergewaltigt und besonders perfide ist
dass der Entführer die Mädchen Briefe an
ihre Eltern schreiben lässt Briefe die
er natürlich nie abschickt aber so
bekommen seine Opfer das Gefühl dass sie
nicht ganz verloren sind obwohl sie es
eigentlich sind denn Mark D hat nicht
vor die Mädchen wieder laufen zu
lassen das ist ein wahrer Horror den
Letizia und Sabine erleben müssen aber
bei aller Grausamkeit die Mädchen leben
das ist zumindest irgendwie die gute
Nachricht die Eltern können ihre Töchter
wieder in die Arme schließen und so gibt
es Hoffnung auch für die anderen
Familien die ihre Töchter immer noch
vermissen vielleicht gibt es ja noch
weitere Überlebende irgendwo in Belgien
in einem Versteck also wird Mar du
weiter verhört und er gesteht in den
folgenden Tagen führt er die Polizisten
zu weiteren Orten an denen er Mädchen
gefangen hält doch die Hoffnung auf
Rettung findet ein jees Ende die beiden
achtjährigen und is werden tot im Garten
verschart aufgefunden sie sind grausam
verhungert als mardtro zwischenzeitlich
wegen Autodiebstahls im Gefängnis saß
und sich niemand um die Kinder gekümmert
hat und das Grauen geht weiter 17 Tage
nach seinem ersten Geständnis führt Dru
die Polizei zu seinem Grundstück in der
Stadt
jum dort finden sie die Leichen von
annmarschall und evje lambrex beide sind
betäubt und lebendig begraben
worden Belgien ist im Schockzustand die
sechs vermissten Mädchen sind gefunden
vier davon tot zwei lebendig und man
fragt sich hätten diese Taten verhindert
werden können die Antwort ist ja denn zu
diesem Zeitpunkt Mitte der 90er Jahre da
hätte magdru eigentlich noch im Knast
sitzen müssen und zwar wegen der
gleichen Taten Entführung und Missbrauch
allerdings ist da noch kein Mord mit dem
Spiel gewesen im Februar
1986 wird Mark dtrou festgenommen
zusammen mit seiner Lebensgefährtin
Michelle Martin wird Marc drou angeklagt
weil sie fünf junge Mädchen und Frauen
entführt und missbraucht haben alle im
Alter zwischen 12 und 19 Jahren im April
1989 wurde D Tru zu 13inhalb Jahren Haft
verurteilt ja und hier wird diese lange
Geschichte zum ersten Mal richtig
unfassbar denn diese 13 Jahre die hat er
nicht annährend abgesessen mag du Tru
darf nach gerade einmal drei Jahren das
Gefängnis wieder verlassen nachdem ihm
der damalige Justizminister begnadigt
hat und das tut er obwohl magdutros
eigene Mutter eindringlich davor warnt
ihn wieder rauszulassen sie selber weiß
wie gefährlich dieser Mann ist aber
diese Warnungen sind vergeblich mag du
Tru kommt frei nicht zuletzt weil er es
schafft sich als Opfer zu inszenieren er
bekommt nach seiner Haft sogar eine
Rente zugesprochen der Grund er hätte
durch die Haft einen seelischen Schaden
erlitten hier lässt sich schon erahnen
dass irgendetwas in der belgischen
Justiz und wohl auch in der belgischen
Politik nicht zusammenpasst schlimm
genug wenn völlig enthemmte und
moralisch verkommene Leute Mädchen
entführen und umbringen der fallmark
drou aber hat das Zeug ein ganzes Land
in den Abgrund zu führen nicht mal seine
eigene Mutter traut Mark über den Weg
und seine Taten wirken als hätte er
Rückendeckung von ganz oben und das
zusammen mit polizeilicher Schlamperei
das ergibt eine Kombination unter der
die Opfer und Belgien noch lange leiden
werden also reichlich Stoff für einen
zweiten Teil dieser schwer fassbaren
Episode vielen Dank dass ihr mit dabei
wart und bis zum nächsten Mal euer Mirko
und eure
Tony
dir hat diese Folge von tartout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland